Pollan is practically indestructible and
it's everywhere in everything but it's
also tiny and unless you have seasonal
allergies and probably barely notice but
100 years ago
Leonard von post realized that these
tiny plant particles have a huge story
to tell the compound that makes up
pollens tough shell called spore opala
ninh is practically indestructible it's
so stable
that pollen from 310 million years ago
can be analyzed for its chemical
similarity to pollen today an ancient
pollen provides some of the earliest
evidence for land plants preserving an
evolutionary record of plant life
studying preserved pollen can tell us
what kind of plants grew in a place that
in turn tells us what the climate must
have been like and how it has changed
over time through radiocarbon dating
pollen could tell us how old the site is
Paul and preserved in the dung of
predators can tell us what they ate and
what their prey was as molecular
techniques improved ancient DNA and
biological molecules from pollen will
provide a wealth of new information
enough to keep pawn scientists busy for
another 100 years